Film Courage: How did you get your first
script in the hands of John Carpenter?
Jim Agnew, Screenwriter/Producer: Well, it was
the first thing I wrote. I’d been working as
a producer on indie films and music videos and
commercials and like I’m going to take the leap
into screenwriting. I saved enough money for
one year to just work on screenwriting and had
this idea to do a very pulp fiction-type horror
film, kind of non-linear. I had a friend who was
a screenwriter (Sean Keller) who had become my
writing partner and we’d never worked together.
We just decided to write it and after three months
just working on the script with no expectations.
We ended up getting a manager from it because
it was so unusual and odd and different than
what was out there. Then from there I get a call
a few weeks later saying John Carpenter read it,
loves it! I grew up watching his movies and by
the way he’s the greatest guy on the face of the
earth. He’s the coolest dude you could ever
meet. He read the script, liked it and was
very interested in directing it. His process was
to sit there with the script and read it aloud to
us page-by-page and everything that he didn’t like
or thought wasn’t good he’d go Come on, you can do
better than that. Which was a learning experience
in itself and it showed, it taught me a lot about
what directors are looking for and what they want
and he’s a great teacher. The film never got made
but it was a really good experience and then from
that we actually did an uncredited rewrite on his
last film THE WARD, so it worked out great because
we got paid to rewrite the film. So we’ve worked
with Carpenter twice and he’s a really good dude.
Film Courage: And so this was the second script
with you and your writing partner?
Jim: That was actually the first one.
Film Courage: Sorry, but how did this manager and
how did all this even get in the hands of John
Carpenter well I had spent time like the first 10
years of work in the film industry I worked for
production companies and produced some indie films
and things so I kind of knew how the business
worked a little bit I had an unfair advantage to
most people just stepping in but I spent 10 years
working in the world and making some connections
and also understanding how scripts work so I
really had worked on a few things where it's like
I could probably write as well as that or even saw
what other people were making and some other
screenplays I was like I think I could do that
so that's kind of where it came out of and just we
also knew that we had to write something that was
really unusual out of the box we didn't write a
script to be made we wrote a script to get noticed
and that's where I think really it worked it was
like okay this gets made that's great but people
will not forget the script and it did what it
was supposed to do because it got us it got us
a manager and then later got us an agent from
another script and just kept the ball rolling
and people still ask me about that script and
we've optioned it I don't know maybe six or seven
times the last 15 years still hasn't been made
but it's it's done well and when you sat down
with John Carpenter where was this like an office
building yeah he has like i'm not going to say
where's office but he has yeah he has an old
craftsman I think maybe he lived there like 20 30
years ago that he still owns it's been converted
into office so it's cool you go in there and all
his posters are up all his scripts are there
he just sits in the back office and just most
of time when we would talk about the script we'd
also talk about basketball and music and all these
other things and he gave me a lot of advice about
the film business he would say people are going to
rip you off they're going to do this they're going
to do that don't start writing until you get paid
do this and that and one of the best stories I
have about him is when we were doing a rewrite
on the ward for him there was a big conference
call with all these producers and everybody kept
telling us what to do and he stopped everyone and
he just said hey let let them go do what they do
and it was the coolest thing because we knew all
we had to do was just talk to carpenter it's like
deal with everybody else and pretty much the
script the rewrite we did was the movie that that
you saw so yeah and when he started going through
the script and saying you can do better than that
did he did he show you what better was within
the script no he no he's he let you he kind
of treated you as a professional it's like this
can be better which means you need to go figure
out how to make it better and just some lines
he'd be like a hero would never say that the
lead of the movie wouldn't say that so it was a
good good education and understanding that like
they're not gonna do the work for me and
things I didn't do correctly in a script
it's like and that's not necessarily their job
it's like this isn't working so you need to give
me option a b and c so that was a really good
lesson from somebody who knows films backwards
and forwards and so when you and Sean left
there with your whether you put paper clips or
post-it notes or whatever how are you racking your
brain to go why didn't he like this what like no
it was just like I can't believe we're hanging
out John Carpenter more more than anything but
he was so he's he's like like he's probably one of
the best people I've ever met not just in the film
business but just a great great person and super
cool and just gives great advice and it was just
he didn't do it because he was from a place of
like come on it was more like you can do better
and he would say you can do better just was really
pushing and really dug the script and to have
somebody who you watch these movies growing up
say that is like you better listen so it was part
it was it's part of educating yourself I still
I've been doing this 15 years professionally as
a screenwriter i'm trying to educate myself
all the time to get better every day so
good lesson and jim were you paid for the script
no that one was just work to try to get it to the
finish line that happens sometimes sometimes
things are options sometimes they're not if
you're you have a good attachment like a director
like him you sometimes work on trying to get to
the next level to go out to get the financing so
not every job every every project you work on is
you're not always getting paid sometimes you have
to you have to make that decision do you want to
do the work to try to get to the next level or
do you want to try to get paid sometimes there's
no one's going to pay you so it's like there's
it's either the market doesn't want it right
now or will want it with attachments or it's a
tricky thing most people in the film business
you won't make money unless multiple people want
to buy the project if just one person wants to
make it they're like sure we'll give you an option
we'll do this we may have optioned that script I
don't really remember but it wasn't it was never
purchased so and a lot of times you just get an
option you don't get paid for a script you read
these stories of people selling a script here or
there that happens but if you're more in the indie
world 10 million and under you option a script
maybe they'll give you five grand maybe they'll
give you 10 grand maybe they'll give you a hundred
dollars and when the movie gets made the first day
of shootings when they actually pay for the script
so if you want to be a team player and get
the movie mate you have to work a lot for free
and so going there you and Sean both knew we're
not going to be paid but we see the opportunity
exactly down the line exactly it was
like having a master class it's like it's
yeah where the guy's sitting there you can
ask me if you want so that's great what's the
story behind your first screenplay sale so first
screenplay sale was the script we wrote after the
John Carpenter project which is called elli gothic
this was called damned and this script was got out
and it was picked up by a pretty big producer and
they arranged the financing for the film and they
actually paid for the script and what happened
was a few days before shooting it was fully cast
I think they were shooting on like a monday
and this was friday the cast was getting on
plane flights to fly out to missouri and they get
these frantic calls like don't get on the plane
because the money fell out three days before
principal photography and that happens sometimes
in films until you're actually I even have the
theory that on an indie film until you're actually
finished shooting you don't that's when you don't
really have to worry about the money so much you
have to worry about post but I've worked on films
where sometimes they don't have all the money they
say they they do so it's a problem that happens
but it was it was sad we got paid at least we got
the rights to script back they were great to give
us that back because the movie didn't get made and
we optioned it several more times but it was it
was very disappointing because that was the first
thing I thought was going to get made and it
didn't it got very close and it just fell apart
but you live and you learn and then you
move on to the next project keep going
so that didn't deter you no not at all no it's
like it was it actually made me think even more
okay we got to work even harder on the next
project and get something made cause it came
so close and finally we're making some money as
screenwriters and we were like let's do it it's
not like no actually it actually emboldened me
to even go harder and things and so in a case
like that who calls the the actors the location
is that's the producer that's yeah making all
these horrible calls that's probably got to be
very difficult yeah and so there was no chance
of maybe in a month it was basically this is
done they they talked about it but usually in
these kind of projects if that happens it's it's
kind of hard to regroup you spend so many months
putting the whole team together doing everything
getting the actors in line getting their schedules
making deals and then for it all to go sideways
and not know when you're going to pick it back up
it's very difficult it does happen don't get me
wrong but it's it becomes like okay there's a
little bit of a jinx on a project at that point
so you just kind of have to move on and just try
to make the next one and sorry this was your first
screenplay that you wrote or you second oh second
okay with Sean yeah okay and with the first one
did you expect anything from that that was the
John Carpenter one the expectations were just to
get noticed really because it was it was really
kind of crazy and that's another thing I talk
to people a lot about it's like what are your
expectations with the script is it if you write
something to sell it or to get it made or to get
noticed and a lot of I think young screenwriters
don't try to write something to get noticed
because if you want to do this for a living
it's something that you've got to like you're
not just going to write one script you're
going to be writing every day all the time
and have tons of scripts do you think the chain
of events would have happened today because things
have changed so rapidly in so many ways do you
think that same story could be duplicated again
either one whether you get a script that you
won't be paid for but into the hands of some
master class person basically a
master definitely happens all the time
a lot of people who become big writers they they
write a script that turns into a sample and even
I've had that several times my career where
there's like a sample of like a horror film
that everybody was into and then a thriller that
everybody was into and then I recently wrote a
really big action film that that's getting a
lot of traction right now but it's also just
in the last few weeks got me up for some big
writing gigs because if you're trying to get
a job for a 80 million dollar action film you
can't show them a one million dollar horror film
you have to have that sample that gets people's
attention and professional high level producers
read they know by your sample if you can do the
other job so you have to have samples that fit
that that kind of what you the type of work
you're looking for so it was a great sample
so your two screenplays that you had one that
was looked at and scrutinized by John Carpenter
the other one that was ready for production and
it fell through a few days beforehand what did
both those situations teach you about writing
they just taught you I mean they taught me to be
just part of the process because you start working
with directors and producers and actors and even
though neither neither of those projects got made
you realize that like you're not an individual in
this process you have to you have to be a team
player you have to work with all these different
people that have their their input and maybe
producer a has some good ideas and producer b
has horrible ideas but producer b might be giving
you the money for the film so it's like how do you
navigate those waters so that was that was what
I took out of those more than anything it's like
it's not I don't get to do what I want but I've
got to try to like navigate to a sense to where
I can make it what I want or win some of the
battles but i'm not going to win them all
and you just don't have a choice when someone pays
you for something they own it it's like it's like
if you sold your house and then you're like well
I don't want them to tear out the hardwood floors
they're going to do it anyway so a lot of it
is is doing that as being figuring out how to
like navigate those waters of like to keep
the integrity of your script and still get
the movie made because that's a very delicate
balance between the two you had been in the
film industry before you said were you working
as a script reader or around script readers
no I actually had worked at streamline pictures
which was the company that brought all the anime
over to America in the 90s I worked for Carl Masik
and how I got that job was I got out of college
I played in a band and the drummer had gotten
a job there marketing and I was like I need a
job so he goes I'll get you one so he got me a job
there and it was a really interesting environment
because streamline was like did so many things
they produced films they they imported films
they created content they they were like really
ahead of the game in a lot of ways and carl masik
was like probably the first mentor I ever had he
passed away a few years ago but he was a great guy
and just kind of let us do our own thing
he'd be like call universal and see if we
can set up this film well how just figure it
out so you'd just be left your own devices so
from that I working at that company I learned a
lot about films and the industry and the business
part which I think is still an advantage I
have over a lot of other people in the film
industry that I understand how the the money
works and where it flows back and forth and
what's the bottom line of making a film so from
there I worked on some indie films I produced some
indie films after that and some commercials some
music videos and just learned about production
as much as I could and didn't even on the indie
films I worked on I didn't just sit in a chair I
sat there with a line producer and learned how
to line by line how to budget a film how to do
all that stuff because it was just like if i'm
going to do this for a living I need to know as
much as I can about everything every department
so that's pretty much what I took away from that
is that something that you think is to your
advantage I mean have you always been that
way where you cut you you don't you you just
need to be told where point b is or a is and
you'll find a way how to get yeah I i'm a little
bit both right brain and left brain so I can i'm
one of those few people that can like do a budget
but I can also write a script there's not a lot
of people like that so I don't know why I can do
that but it's it's you you when you understand the
business points of like why people are investing
two three million dollars in a film and what they
want out of it it becomes a little bit easier to
shape the creative side too how'd that help it did
what would you say to people that say well I
only do this though I mean I mean some people
think that what it was jack of all trades master
of none and they don't they don't want to get
in that situation but then there's a real power
in knowing how many different things work yeah
and and here's the thing this is what I
always try to the more about the film business
the better it's going to help you you don't have
to be an expert but you have to kind of understand
how things work because this is the one thing
I always I always try to explain to people that
are want to get into screenwriting they'll be like
hey I wrote the script it's my first script I want
to get it out to producers I want to send it to
people I want to get it made and they want someone
who they don't know who's who they've never
made money for to give them two million dollars
now if you just take that aside and you think
that you want to start a restaurant but you've
never worked one day in a restaurant you've
never even been in the kitchen of a restaurant
and you write a business plan for a restaurant
and you go to somebody who invests in restaurants
and say can I have two million dollars for this
restaurant they're gonna think you're crazy but
for some reason screenwriters think oh I wrote the
script someone should give me two million dollars
it's yet it's their first script it's their first
business plan they haven't spent any time in the
industry and think somebody's gonna write a check
for two million dollars because it's that good
I mean maybe there are a couple scripts they're
that good that people just can throw millions
of dollars at you but there's like that's like a
handful on the planet so people don't understand
it's like that's one of the things that like I try
to instill in people is like if you want to be a
screen screenwriter and do it professionally
you maybe your sixth or seventh will be
good enough to show to a producer your first
script about your uncle isn't going anywhere
and there's millions of those and that's
the problem is like it's not hard to become
a professional screenwriter but you have to
do the work and you have to understand the
business that's what people don't do a lot of
times and is there a hazing with all the knocks
that you're going to get and all the stuff that's
going to be the plug's going to be pulled and then
yeah you have to have very very thick skin
and something that took me a long time to
understand too is you have to interpret notes
because sometimes producers don't like something
but they can't tell you what they don't like so
they say no a and it kind of doesn't make sense
you have to figure it out you have no guideline
because there's I've worked with both kinds of
producers really fantastic a-list producers and
other ones that are good at like putting a film
together but can't articulate the creative side
so you have to figure out what they don't like
and that's your job and that sometimes it's
just alchemy you're like you've got to get
inside their head and understand why they don't
like the first act and when we hear about these
wunderkind or whatever that's like their first
thing and then it's picked up and it's probably
more so maybe in the past I don't know how much
does that spoil us as writers or creatives because
we think oh i'm going to be the next one yeah
it does I mean it does because those stories
get told over and over but they're so few and far
between I know a lot of filmmakers I know a lot
of directors I know a lot of writers and there's
very few films that completely change your life
it's more like a stepping stone from this to this
like maybe you'll do this movie and then you'll
get that one you'll direct a bigger move you went
from directing a million dollar movie to 5 million
to 30. but there are those things where people get
hit by lightning but I always try to say that 50
of of getting a project put together is super
hard work being talented staying focused and
the other 50 is timing and luck because the market
can change within minutes because we had a script
that was this thriller that people liked we
put it on the market and we had some people
really interested in it and then taking came out
like two weeks later and then suddenly my agent
got like 20 calls like the next morning hey that
and it wasn't really even like taken but it just
was like a revenge thriller and it's like so
suddenly the script that everybody's kind of into
becomes everybody's into because something was a
hit so you can't control that you can't control
the market you have to just do the best
work and hope that it goes somewhere sure
it found footage yeah yeah yeah things change so
something you wrote even now like I've had people
like talk to me about like older scripts like hey
what about that and i'm like I don't even want to
send it to you because I feel like a i'm a better
writer and b things have changed it's just that
was written 12 years ago it's not the same kind
of way movies are made because things do evolve
I think I've heard you say it's not about selling
a screenplay it's about getting the movie made yes
yes how how are those two things different
well I mean you you could sell screenplay if
you want to make some money and that's
great but the in my mindset it's like
if I love this script and I want to get made I not
only want to get paid but I want to get it made
because in the long term sure you make
some money but the reason a lot of us
are doing this is to create things so if it's a
document that's just sitting there in a drawer
not many people are going to see it but if it's on
Netflix or something you can get out of the world
so yeah I try to like be very focused
on like how do I get a movie made
but I also have a personality where once I start
getting into some I won't let it go until and just
push and push and push the movie Rage which we
did with Nick Cage that movie took five years to
get made and it was like a five-year like hall of
constantly working and pushing it up the hill at
one time antoine fuqua actually often optioned
the script he was going to direct it and that
would have been fantastic and then we had this
other director and other people were involved
one time ethan hawk was going to be the movie it
just kept falling apart getting put together but
we had to have that tenacity of like all these
setbacks the script's too good not to get made
and a lot of people said it's a great script it's
too bad it didn't get made so i'm like okay well
it's gonna get made and it took us five years to
get it made and it finally got made but it's it's
just a different kind of mindset of like if you
want to be in the film business obviously the end
game is to get movies made the flip
side of that which is kind of like
strange is that sometimes you can get hired
to write a tv pilot that never gets made and
you make a lot more money than a film that does
get made so you have to kind of temper that like
don't get me wrong i'm i'm a capitalist and I love
getting paid but I also want to get a movie made
and completed and finished so were you always like
this where you wanted to see something through to
the end yeah i'm very good so i'm also i'm working
on not being miserable until it's finished I have
a bad habit of like not enjoying the process
which I've got much better at the last few years
but it's kind of a mindset like you have to just
be focused on like the the finish line and not
let go until it's done because movie a million
things can go wrong even even after you shoot it
everything can go wrong in post you could run out
of money things could go sideways the the editor
does a bad job we had a director on a film we had
a fire in post and I had to do the sound mix and
the other producer had to do the color timing so
and we had to reshoot the beginning so it's a it's
a process but we got the movie finished so let's
take that screenwriter though that is that first
screenplay that's he's writing about his uncle his
uncle has a pawn shop and he just he's the coolest
guy and everybody needs to see this film at what
point do you tell that person and they have this
tenacity I don't think it's gonna work yeah that's
a good question but they have to also kind of like
have some self-reflection of like what is this
script doing for producers like at the end of
the day every movie is made for one reason it's
not a creative endeavor it's to make money I mean
secondarily it's creative endeavor but you have to
make money unless you find some rich uncle who's
a billionaire just wants to throw tax shelters at
you that's a whole different story but if it's not
working that script what's wrong with that script
is there not a market for it does it do producers
not you know have do they not get sparked to it
what is the thing that's going to get you to the
to the next level if that script's not working
write another script write something maybe more
commercial write something more personal what
what is not connecting with people on that script
because the thing is what I hear from agents and
managers all the time is like 99 of scripts I get
are horrible people pitching them things are
horrible ideas and it's like if you write some
if you write well and you have a great script it
will get noticed it might not get made you might
not get money but you'll get some kind of notice
on it but what is the level of that good script
is it did you spend three months on it did you
spend two years and keep rewriting the same script
over and over sometimes things don't work I mean
I don't know on my computer the other day I found
probably 40 scripts that were half written or the
first act and i'm like okay it's not working it
didn't come out the way I thought it was and
I don't see how it's gonna be great to sell
I actually have two full scripts
right now I've written that like
I thought were gonna be great i'm like I don't
know they're not what I want to put out right now
so I just put them away maybe I'll come back them
later maybe I'll never even look at them again
but if you want to work as a professional writer
and work all the time that's what you've got to
do is just keep grow one script isn't going to
make a career so follow-through is great tenacity
but at some point having some type of an
awareness that when you're getting notes or
you're just getting just complete rejection that
there's a sign there yes yes okay and sometimes
it's good like if you're working on something
that's not working people are not you know
having any kind of reaction to it try something
else put it away write another kind of script
see what people feel I mean the problem is too
a lot of people give scripts to their friends
and ask their opinion they just go that's great
or or even people who don't know a script from
don't work in the film business you which that's
kind of like a problem too it's like I know a
lot of people subscribe to these like they pay
for coverage or they pay for script notes and
who's giving you those script notes somebody who's
never worked on a movie maybe they know a little
bit more about you so you have to be very careful
those things can be very educational and can help
but you I don't I don't ever like when people
spend a ton of money on those things because I
feel like they're getting ripped off at some point
because if you want to learn how to make a movie
the templates there there's hundreds of thousands
of movies on Netflix you can watch that have been
made you just have to find movies like what you
want to do if you want to write a personal story
or a story about you and your friends and some
girl dumped you watch swingers the template's
there it doesn't have to be the same story but
you can follow the beats and you can see how
it flows and where you the second act turn
happens and where the resolution comes in
and what's the arc it's it's all been done for
you making it sound really easy aren't I well
some people are self-aware and some people aren't
so yeah have you ever paid for script coverage
have you ever no you've never no I've never read
a book about how to write screenplay or anything
but I found that I work a lot of intuition but I
also but what I do though sometimes and even now
that I've been doing this i'm in the writers guild
I've done it for a long time make a living at this
even recently I pulled up a script
for a film because I wanted to do
I was thinking about a spy idea that was
very similar I found the script online
I put the movie on on amazon prime and followed
the script with the movie I don't need to do that
but I did it anyway just to follow the beats
and see what got shot what then that's a great
exercise for people because sometimes the
script you can see what's in it and what's not
but i'm like this has already been done for
me it's a different story I have a completely
different idea of a different story but this spy
movie was awesome so i'm just gonna watch where
all the beats happen and the formula is there
because making a film is like a pop song it's
there in the box it's two hours long or 90 minutes
to two hours you're not reinventing the wheel
we were talking off camera about the exorcist
and friedkin and bill blatty and I think you
just mentioned something about rhythm and I
remember that billboard talked about good writing
has a rhythm we talk about that in terms of
screenwriting yeah you have to really understand
the rhythm of a of a film like think of it like
you you've we've all seen lots of films you have
to think of it like here's the opening where do we
go now then what do you see next then when do you
go back to that character then when do you see the
bad guys show up for the first time you innately
you should understand those rhythms because
they've been done time and time again maybe
that script wasn't originally written like that
but when they shot it they edited it like that but
there's a rhythm to films which is an any good
film in any successful film which you have to kind
of pay attention to like you don't stay with one
character I mean if it's a character study that's
a little different but if it's an action film
you don't stay with character a through the whole
movie you have to go see the bad guy you have to
go set up what's going on here you have to go do
this and you have to have this like understanding
of rhythm because the rhythm on the page is what's
going to get you to the next level the directors
is going to make the movie and he's going to edit
it but if you don't have that those beats in time
and you spend six pages with one guy talking about
something people reading it are just going to tune
out so you have to have this like really phonetic
rhythm of like that happens and when to end on
a scene be like that's a great beat to end on
cut away to somebody's doing something else
cleaning up a dead body what it was whoa catching
the next scene and keeping the rhythm going
where somebody's reading they're like okay okay
okay okay so really good filmmakers do that in the
films but you can apply it to your script as well
can you name three films that has have an
excellent example of rhythm that a new geez
there's like I just said there's a million I
mean one one guy who's really good at rhythm
is matthew vaughn like if you watch his movies
like everything from layer cake to like the
kingsman movies those things have just a rhythm
it's like we go here we do that we introduce
this we do introduce that we introduce this but
there's always two scripts I always tell people
to to watch I mean sorry two films if you want
to learn about screenplay writing and they sound
corny but they're two of the best like films to
understand how scripts work one of them is karate
kid because the first 10 minutes of that movie
so much about the characters and it's so organic
I mean even when daniel larusso shows up at
his new house with his suitcases he has to kick
the gate in and he goes yeah and then the kid
behind the gate gets knocked over goes do karate
I know karate you know it's so simple and so easy
to understand all the characters you you see what
happens to them or what they're doing and you
understand the characters and within 15 minutes
everybody in the movie what they're about how did
they introduce mr miyagi mr miyagi oh the sink's
broke can you go find the handyman so it's very
natural and organic and quick that movie just goes
so those are all in place and then the other
film I always tell people watch is urban cowboy
because that has such a great rhythm of like
almost using no exposition it just kind of goes
okay he's leaving at this house to go live here
he's going to do this he's going to do that he
meets this girl they get in a fight and the next
thing you see is it's their wedding and they're
taking photos it's just got this this pacing
that explains so much without bogging you down
in exposition so that's kind of what rhythm you
have to really pay attention so those are two more
movies that are really good with the rhythm do you
think a lot of new screenwriters they get too hung
up on one character you were saying before like
you have to keep it moving yeah not not only that
but they get hung up on like id things they want
to see in a movie that's a big turning point when
you're writing professionally you have to realize
that like what that cool scene you want to write
and you put in the script it's not going
to work and you have to take it out
because there'll be things where like you
it gets stuck in your head you have to kill
I mean kill your darlings you've heard
it time and time again but it's true
you have to do whatever's right to service
the script and sometimes it's like you might
have written this like amazing intro that you
love but does nothing for the story so it's got
to go or you have to do another one but you
have to like do that and I mean look there's
directors I've worked I've worked with some great
directors I work with some directors that like
want to do something so they're wedging stuff into
the script and it always goes sideways it's like
they saw somebody who did like long runners
and just in a movie recently and they're like
well let's take these five scenes and make it a
one-shot scene and then it screws the story up
but they don't care because it's like they want to
see it so you can't get caught up in like things
you want to do and see that don't work for the
story what do you say to the screenwriter who says
it's not their job to get the movie made it's just
their job to have ideas and come up with a story
they probably won't get any movies made I mean
it's it's a team process it's like if you get
to a certain level where you can get paid very
well for screenplays you can have that mindset
but those are high level professionals that are
like yeah I got paid a half million dollars to
do this and that and good luck and they know
it's a money gig and maybe it might get made
maybe it won't but if you want to like work more
in the 10 million under like indie film trenches
you've got to like really be part of
the process or what happened you'll
just be cut out of it completely they'll they
won't ask you and then you'll watch a movie
and this has happened to me it's something that
I worked on that like I wasn't really part of
the pro and you don't it's not even your script
it's not your story and your name's on it so it's
it's in your best interest to stay involved in
the process and to be a team player and nobody
wants to deal with a negative writer either if
you're like no those ideas are bad or that's bad
you have to kind of frame it in a way that like
that's good what about this oh yeah you because
you have to become very if you're going to do this
for a living you have to not let criticism affect
you you have to just be like okay if somebody
doesn't like something no big deal because
other people that don't do this all the time
like some producers and some actors and stuff
they're very precious about their ideas
and can get very emotionally hurt if you
just go no that's bad so you have to like be a
little bit of a a therapist and and somebody who
understands what the other people are thinking
why they're even asking these things because I
one of the best things I ever learned was this
one actor i'm not gonna say it was had a really
bad idea on this movie and kept saying it over and
over and it made no sense and I said the director
one day I was like why does he keep talking about
this bad idea and the director said look he goes
guys like us we have a hundred ideas a day we
throw away 99. guys like him has one idea every
six months he can't let it go and that was
a big light bulb it's like well that's why
he likes that bad idea because he doesn't have any
other ideas so you have to kind of manage that and
be part of the process or they'll just leave you
behind they'll just go make the movie without you
do you literally have like a hundred ideas I mean
are you let's say in line waiting with a mask to
let you let into the grocery store and you're like
oh wait what that lady reminds me of this that
would make the perfect sense I probably come up
i'm not kidding i'd probably come up with at least
10 ideas for films a week if not
more and write them down and some are
just some have legs you have to kind of like I
have a system where I try to figure out if it's
actually a story or script but yeah I
come up with them all the time like I mean
literally all the time there used to be a joke
pitch that my writing partner I used to do
sometimes to lighten the room when we'd be
just in a meeting we'd say oh we got this
idea for this movie it's like it's point break
on motorbikes and the cyclones are coming in
and yeah or the tornadoes are coming in they have
to rob the banks before tornadoes hit and this
fbi agent has to infiltrate the group it was a
joke idea somebody sold that exact same script
for like a half a million dollars a few years
later like no I don't think they stole our id
or anything it's just in the ether but it's
what seemed like a joke idea is somebody else
so it's like you have to have a lot of ideas and
you have to know like what ideas are gonna work
because they're I've worked on a few scripts that
are great fantastic scripts and nobody wants to
make them because there's just this issue or that
issue the producers think it's too hard it won't
make its money back so it's a it's a balance
between the business side and the creative side
so when you do have a great idea what is your
process for at least putting it somewhere that
you can come back to and how do whether you
want to take it further I usually I email them
to myself so I have all these random emails that
that half the time don't make sense like you know
second act on on a plane giant fight guy loses his
wife hitman finds out his ex-wife is married to
somebody else yeah things like that so I have all
these weird random things but then once I really
dig in I have a process to figure out if something
can be a script and usually it's I figure out the
entire first act beat by beat by beat like the
first 20 pages this happens that happens this
happens like the first six or seven scenes then I
know what happens in the second hack turn kind of
what shifts the movie or the story and then how
it ends and if I can figure all that out then I
know I pretty much can write a pretty good script
so that's usually what I do first I don't want to
know the whole story beat by beat by beat because
I figured some things out along the way that I
would have never thought of now there's other
times I've kind of thought the whole thing out
almost in more bigger beats and bigger sections
but that's usually what I do is I know the first
act how it ends what happens in the middle
and then what happens at the end and that's it
so it starts as an idea you could be pumping gas
somewhere and you go quickly and email yourself
this little like log line or whatever and then
from there on a weekend maybe when you have quote
spare time you go and try to do the first 20
pages yeah usually the ideas that that I can't
stop thinking about are the ones I know are good
they keep popping back in my head because there's
some ideas you just come up with nah throw it away
it's pretty good but it's not great but the ones
that keep reoccurring are the ones that I feel
like okay I gotta work on this there's something
here because it's stuck in my head and also too
ideas are great testing ground with people too
I mean this is for more like commercial type
films but if you can pitch an idea in two three
sentences to somebody just your friends or whoever
and they kind of do this weird thing I've noticed
this is when you have a good idea not when people
go that's great when they think about it for about
three seconds and they go oh that's good that's
when it's actually connecting with people so if
you have an idea and you say that to 10 people and
they kind of all go or they ask you about it again
later it's a good idea so if I tell you I have
this great script about my uncle and he's really
cool he has a pawn shop in hoboken and he's just
a really funny guy and he always knows when some
fence is coming in to like and yeah and I look
at you and you go what are you going to tell me
if you want to take the time to write that but
no I mean it might be the greatest script ever
but I've noticed that's one thing I've noticed too
is that the screenplays that get a lot of traction
and get a lot of people's interest or things
that can be described in two three sentences
because a lot of times if you're pitching the
idea or a creative exec reads it they have to
go down the hall and pitch it to their boss so
it's too complicated it's going to get lost in
translation so if it's something that we saw
the tv show that like everybody understood the
pitch in two sentences I think that's why it
kept just snowballing and snowballing because
it was like okay great everybody got it without
reading the pilot without it was like okay good
so those kind of things seem to really
work with people at least getting
you through the front door if the scripts bad it's
not gonna go anywhere but you have to make things
digestible for people too that are working you
have to keep in mind producers real producers are
working like 20 30 projects in development hearing
pitches all day talking about things working on
films if you give them some overly complicated
idea about your uncle in a pawn shop they're
going to be like wait what'd you say again like
10 minutes later so there's that how long after
selling your first screenplay did you sell your
second it happened pretty quick because the next
screenplay I don't know if it was the next thing
we wrote but i'd come up one day I was at the
tower records the old one that used to have a
video you could rent videos and dvds sunset yes
they had two the one across the street
the one that had the dvd store in it
and I was looking at dvds I was like I had this
idea it was like Dario Argento I saw his he had
a section I was like his movies are cool and
I watched a lot of his movies from the 70s
it's like we should do a retro kind of Dario
Argento film and that was when horror was really
hitting its peak in like 2007 2008 so it's
like let's just write like a 70s jello type
thing that has all those tropes and just have fun
with it and we did and literally like I don't know
how this happens is like two months later this
friend of mine who's from Italy goes oh you have
something like Dario's movies I'll send it to
Dario or like like okay I didn't really know
this guy that well so and then I get a call
like a week later and Dario Argento on the
phone from Italy he's like I love your script
I want to do it so that movie got made I don't
the universe just wanted that movie to get made
we had a lot of problems with the production but
it was just strange it was like one day it's like
and sometimes the universe just kind of leads you
in right in certain directions because I just was
like I like his movies let's do something like his
a retro 70s throwback film and then he literally
directed it and Adrien Brody was in it so it's
how does this happen from from the concept of
being in that video store like a year later I
was in Italy on set so sometimes things just have
a weird synergy projects have a weird synergy too
that's the other thing people have to realize it's
happened to me on so many where i'm banging my
head trying to get this movie made and it's just
not working and then sometimes you write something
and every step of the way it just snows balls
it it connects at the right time and right place
I don't know why but it just does and
that did and it's about a missing model
yeah because that's what all the 70s movies
were about like missing pretty girls so it it
leaned into all those tropes of it it was like
this this girl who was a model went missing her
sister's looking for her in a and doesn't speak
the language and finds this America n who actually
does and helps her out so yeah the movies cut some
problems but it was it was fun to make and it was
a great adventure and dario's an amazing person
and a great director another again I've been I
feel like I've had the million dollar film school
because I've got to work with so many great people
so yeah so that was that was that taught me a lot
about how things can go wrong on a movie which
i'm not going to go into too much detail but a
lot of stuff went wrong mostly with the money
and the budgets and we didn't have as much
money to finish the film so halfway through
you find that out it's like it's it was a
real a lot of problems not creatively but
on the business end of the film was it filmed in
Italy yeah oh I see okay yeah great wow it looks
like a good I gotta go to Italy for three months
yeah that's nice that was fun to sell a screenplay
do you have to really believe you can sell it
yeah yeah I think you need to believe in the in
the screenplay you have to believe in yeah because
it's a hustle especially if it's your first one so
you need to really believe in it it needs to be
something that you believe in something that you
think you can sell and you just need to be kind of
relentless but if it doesn't work out you need to
move on to the next script because the question
is you need to ask yourself as an up-and-coming
screenplay writer if you want to do this for a
living do you want to write things for yourself
to direct do you want to be a working screenwriter
because if you're if you get to the level where
you're taking jobs which has happened to me
on several projects i'm getting hired to write
something there's like an adaptation of a book
or a comic book so I don't have any say in the
creative thing but you can get paid very well to
like do that work so are you doing it for yourself
are you doing it because you want to constantly
write now if you want to do it as a living
in that sense where you're writing all the time
you don't get to choose all the time what you want
to write you may have to do a rewrite you may have
to do this so it becomes more about work than like
just believing just in the project you have
to believe in yourself and it becomes more
about like just doing the work and doing the
work correctly and efficiently and on time
so when things haven't panned out have you
had like a heart to heart with yourself like
well I didn't really believe in it yeah no
I think because most those those projects
I'll get rid of them before they get to that point
like I won't finish them or even if I do I'll be
honest about like I don't think everybody's gonna
want to buy this I think it's great but no one's
going to want to make it because the other thing
too is like you have to really realize that in
regards to indie films or smaller 10 million
under film the only way they're really going
to get financed unless you have a rich uncle is
that you have to have actors in them you have to
name actors that finance the film you can't just
ask somebody for five million dollars and say
the guy from vampire diaries who's the fifth
lead is gonna be the lead in it it's not gonna
work they're gonna wanna name actor they're going
to be like okay we want Frank Grillo and we want
John Travolta we want to make sure that we can
make our money back so you have to also think
too is that project appealing to actors that will
get your movie made because that's a big important
component to the whole process so you've been
in situations where you think you like it but
you don't think others will or a producer well
how do that that's the case just instinct just
kind of knowing what and it might not be
the right time to put something out too
because it's like okay these movies are hot horror
movies are hot right now all anybody wants to make
are these so you just have to be really honest
with yourself and it you can send it but you
only have so many shots of like getting people
to read things too if you keep sending them junk
you're not gonna get anywhere even even i'm very
careful never to send my agents and managers
too much stuff because I'll be like oh that
was okay so I only try to send them the best
stuff that I do can you think of a screenplay
of yours that you did not think would sell
and did yes broken vows which was made with jamie
alexander and wes bentley yeah it was just it was
a script that my writing partner and I wrote and
then we weren't really too happy with it we knew
it was good but it wasn't great and we just kind
of stuck it in a drawer and then I got a call like
two or three years later from a producer friend
of mine said hey do you got anything that can be
made for two and a half million dollars and we're
looking for a thriller or something in that genre
so I was like yeah here we we never sent this out
we never gave it to our agent even to read check
it out it's good we could maybe work on a little
bit more make it better and then I get called like
a week later like okay cool we got the financing
let's make it so that was like literally like
just finding a movie in a drawer because it was
just sitting in a file but I also think two part
of that is that goes back to what i'm saying about
some of the stuff that I think is not up to to par
it's still I've written some some things that are
very professional and could get made but I don't
want to like take my shots with those because I
just think they're not maybe they're 90 they're
not 100. so I think even something that on my 90
because I've worked on so many things is still
good enough to turn into a film the opportunity
just arose that this was a good opportunity to
take that film that was like 90 there and
they were looking for something like that
so it worked great did you think it was
too edgy no it just seemed I don't know
I don't know why it just didn't it didn't
even click with the writers in some ways
we knew it was good but it didn't click with us
but then we worked out a little bit more once it
got serious and then it became a different kind
of film and became a little bit better so I don't
know it was just a weird situation where it was
just script was sitting in a drawer and ended up
getting fully financed and made with great actors
and I think the actors brought a lot to it too
so it was one of those projects that and that's
what you always want is your screenplay can be
here but hopefully the the finished products
one step better sometimes it goes the other
direction where I have one movie which i'm
not going to say which movie which everybody
who saw in the film business was a screenplay
was great which that's very disheartening when
it should get a step or two better when when
it's shot and edited and made into a film
broken vowels was like like a romantic deception
or yeah what was it sorry it's been a while
yeah it was like a stalker movie but the
guy was a stalker usually you saw it as
as the girls the stalker now they've had quite
a few of those I think we wrote it like 2008
and then it got made in 2013. so it was it
was that the guy was like obsessed with the
woman and I mean they've made quite a few of
those since then so and it was wes bentley
that yeah the obsessed oh yes yeah yeah
he's great great to work with great guy so
yeah and so from that time that you got that call
where they said hey what do you got hanging around
when was the movie actually finished what was
the time for him probably about a year later
and we had to do the post everybody chipped in
I did the sound mix the other producer did the
color timing so it took a little bit longer to
get made but yeah so it was made and I think
lion's gate lines get distributed so so when they
said what do you have you said well I've got this
thing and you kind of were almost talking them out
of it before no just I didn't know what they were
really looking for so it was just it was like okay
you've got this certain amount of money that you
want to invest in a film you're looking for this
type of film but I did tell them from the get-go
I was like this is the kind of film we can easily
cast because it's got some good parts for actors
and they're between 25 and 35 which is a really
good spot to find some good actors and we did
what no bs screenwriting advice can you give to
young screenwriters or even older who've never
sold something and think that they can make a
living at this well you gotta really be realistic
you have to look at the steps involved if and
what is your end game do you want to get a movie
made it's a small movie what kind of movie is it
are you writing a kind of studio type script are
you writing kind of a a small intimate thing
that can be made for half a million dollars
so you have to kind of set the parameters of
what you want to do and kind of take it from
there because if you're a young screenwriter and
you want to do this for a living I mean you need
to write a couple samples and write some scripts
you need to be around the film business tv's given
a lot of opportunities to being on writing staff
there's so many tv shows now too that's a great
way to becoming a writer you can become a writer's
assistant get to know the the working writers
and you'll actually get paid taking notes doing
things and learn how it all works and that that
will help you with jobs if you're a little
bit older I mean you should really work on
work on your screenplays but also determine what
do you want to do is it something that you want
to try to get made on your own do you want to try
like it's a little bit different are you writing
a john wick movie or are you writing a small
intimate thing because if it's a john wick movie
that means you have to sell it through the studio
system that's very hard to break into until you
like are working at a certain level it does happen
but you usually have to work your way up you don't
just all of a sudden you're not up for like these
gigantic jobs of writing 100 billion dollar films
so that's that's a whole kind of skill set
into itself so my advice would be just just
keep working but work on your craft because
people don't do that they don't they don't
take the time to actually keep rewriting and
learning to write they write one thing and they
think here it is world and that that's why it
doesn't get made and then they get frustrated
but I think anybody who's going to take if you're
determined and you want to take 10 years of your
life working super hard to get somewhere you can
get somewhere you get some movies made you can
you can do it for a living but you have to really
like buckle down and be like okay am I gonna like
save enough money for a year that's kind of what
I did I said i'm just gonna save enough money so I
don't have to work for your focus on this or just
really and being in la is a big part of it too
it really is unfortunately it's like it's hard to
become a professional screenwriter when you're in
missouri or somewhere because a lot of the
connections you make and people you meet
I ran into a friend of mine who's a big producer
at the coffee bean one day I hadn't seen her
a while and she said what do you what are you
working on I go well we got this zombie thing
and she goes oh call me later and then we got
paid to write it for for a huge company so it's
like but those are relationships I developed for
a long time but if I wasn't in la I would have
ran into her it's it's these are just things that
happen and so it's that's another part of it too
so you have to be in the gate you have
to be around it you can't just be outside
of it because there's a lot to learn a lot of
people to meet it's all about relationships too
what year was this that you had saved up
the money so that you could live for a year
I think it was 2005. oh okay so the economy was
doing well so yeah I produced I produced a movie
with David Boreanas and then I did a big music
video and got paid well on both those so it's
like okay now's the time so yeah because I didn't
want to keep producing films because producing
producing is fun I like producing but
it's different it's not that creative
so I was just like now's the time so what I did is
I just planned for a whole year it's like okay i'm
just going to focus on this and it worked but i'd
worked around i'd been in the business and worked
in the business and knew people so it wasn't
coming out from somewhere moving to l.a in a small
apartment just going okay I got a year to make
it but if you want to do it you can do it it's
not the good thing about screenwriting it doesn't
take a ton of money to do it you don't it's I mean
if you want to make a short film that you have to
hire a crew you have to shoot to write even the
other day a really big a-list director not to say
it was he goes writing's free if you want to just
sit and write and do as many drafts you want you
it's your time but it doesn't cost you anything
so day one of that like we're doing this i'm
not i'm not taking any new commitments on
what was your did you like schedule things out did
you have it on a calendar today no I wish I was
that I wish I was that organized it was a lot of
intuition just like okay now feels like the time
so no it wasn't I wish it was more planned out
but sometimes some of this stuff just happens
but you have to be in the game for it to happen I
put myself in the situation where it's like okay
this is all i'm gonna do and just talk to people
about it annoyed agents that I knew I was like hey
I wrote the script i'm working on the script
and they didn't care even though I knew them
they're like great good luck but I was like
okay this is the time now to be really focused
on on just and not really having a plan b and how
many hours a day did you write during that year
probably like three or four but I think after four
hours you get a little bit like diminished returns
now that doesn't mean the other five or six hours
a day i'm not thinking about the writing like but
physically sitting there behind the keyboard
usually you try to limit to like four hours
because after four hours you start getting if the
work starts getting a little like not there you're
not sharp why keep writing but i'm always thinking
about things like a lot of things when I write
I don't touch keyboard until I've figured out
the whole for like I said the whole first act
the second act turn and I will I can sit
down one day and write 20 pages but I've
thought about it for two or three weeks and maybe
just wrote out and beats what's going to happen
and then it's not the best 20 pages in the
world but I could do it one day in a couple
hours but I know where everything's going to fit
and what the beats are and then I'll go back and
rewrite the dialogue and rework the scenes but
I know what's going to so after a year did you
say okay time to start making money again or you
it just naturally progressed it started happening
oh okay yeah so got lucky in that sense very
nice and then that film you ended up selling it
yeah the second the second script
we wrote second script oh yeah
yeah that was the one that didn't get made but
yeah I got paid for that and that was a nice that
was a good feeling I would think that was the
first time I ever got paid to be creative I've
been I've worked on films but that's a little bit
different kind of creativity as being a producer
but being creative it was it's like the greatest
feeling in the world to like do something creative
and get paid well for it you're like what
this actually you can actually do this and
that's a that's a big inspiration once you get
that once it becomes kind of a rush it's like
oh hey this is better than working at starbucks
not that I ever worked but or going to an office
yeah much better than going to an office yeah
did you have office jobs no no I mean in the
film industry I did I always I was very lucky
I just but I always kind of angled myself
to where I had a cool job because I didn't
want to be bored at work that was like the only
mantra I had it was like I don't want to be bored
what do you think makes you different from the
other screenwriters who have come to Hollywood
during the same time where you've been able to
make a career at this and possibly they haven't
I think understanding the business because I was
in the business part of it first and producing
and just knowing like how distribution works
knowing like what they how how actors sell films
and things like that because it just you
kind of can filter it through a different
kind of lens where it's like okay this
is what people are looking for because
I've been to afm I've been to can I've been to
sundance on the business side of it so you see
all those posters you see what kind of movies
they're trying to put together and you also see
how many movies are being put together it's like
astronomical if you go to afm how many films are
tens of thousands of them and maybe a finite
number of those get made but you see a reoccurring
theme and you kind of understand how these people
work and it just depends on on what kind of like
level you're at to studio level is completely
different i'm talking more about the indie world
but breaking into the studio world is very
difficult as well he said you have to work
your way up on that so I think that gave
me advantage that was just understanding
the business and I can also put myself in the
mindset of a producer when i'm writing something
and I know okay the producer's not gonna like that
but they'll like this so that helps where someone
else may have come out but they had no prior film
industry experience and so even though it's a very
personalized story it just won't work because
it doesn't tick these different boxes exactly
and like who's going to be like like we talk
about the the movie about your uncle who runs a
a pawn shop what actor is dying to play that part
that can finance a film and then that turns into
a whole other conversation all together because
there's so few actors at certain levels that can
finance a film that's the reason you see so many
bruce willis movies Nick Cage movies John Travolta
movies there's not a big pool of people that can
justify people spending 5 10 20 million dollars
so that's part understanding that's a big part
of it as well how does genre factor in getting
a movie made well this is a very important
thing too to remember is that the reason you
see so many action films on Netflix and things
like that is because action films and thrillers
translate internationally if you want to make a
comedy and it's a comedy about a bunch of kids
in New Jersey and they're going through their
last summer before they graduate high school and
there's a bunch of jokes about America n kids in
New Jersey that's not going to translate in like
Malaysia they're not going to understand it so
those movies have no very little international
value but now action and thrillers sci-fi
and horror is like an international language
that's why you see so many of those films because
they can sell not only in America but all around
the world and that's also something you need
to keep in mind if you have this small intimate
film that you want to make about the
screenplay that's about four sisters
in ohio and it's a comedy drama it's like
you've got a very small audience for that
so that's why producers don't like things
like that and that's why when you look you
can see so many of those action thrillers on
Netflix because they make money internationally
but what if it's in someone's heart I don't
mean to sound so cheesy but what if it's
what if it's in someone's dna that they just want
to make a coming-of-age story and to them they
have to get that story out there and they want
to finish it well I mean if you're a screenwriter
like that that's got that story I think you should
become a filmmaker if it's that that story is like
figure out a way to make the 10 000 version of
that or the 50 000 version of it and make it
that's that's the thing is like you've
probably got a better chance of like
cobbling together your friends and making
a decent movie of that and maybe getting in
some film festivals getting noticed like that
then just sending your script out to people
so that's what I would suggest now
that takes money and resources but
if that's your passion project spend a few years
putting together all those resources or figure out
a way to shoot it there's there's great films
that have been made for ten thousand dollars
you just have to understand how filmmaking works
that's a whole nother conversation altogether but
you can do it I think we've already touched on
this but is it correct that you didn't get an
agent until you sold your first script I had a
manager and then when we sold the second script
there was article about the Hollywood reporter
and then literally that next morning there was
like 10 agents called now you don't always need
here's the thing is agents are great but they're
not a magic bullet for your career either they do
things for you and managers do too but you have to
do a lot on your own you have to meet producers
you have to get out there you have to do things
and I think actually part of that what got the
ball rolling on that that film was was people
really dug the script but I think the reason we
got involved with those producers because i'm
forgetting some of this stuff is a friend of mine
who'd worked with me on a film that I had produced
who was a production coordinator was now
working for them as a development exec
and she was like you should check out
their script so it all kind of tied
together from one thing into another so
it's all about those relationships again
what was the title of the article dom just it was
one of those generic sold sold a script but back
to the agent manager thing it's like they're great
to have but they they work they only have so much
resources to give you you can't like rely on
them for everything even if they care and they
they take the time to read but they have 20 other
clients so you have to like really understand what
how to use them as well have a relationship where
because they they're both they have a bottom line
they have to make money too so a lot of people
think oh I just want an agent manager but you
have to think what are you providing them are you
selling things do you have things you can sell
are they going to take you on as a client and
build your career so where are you in the process
as well what do you provide for them and so when
you got those calls the next day how did who which
person you wanted to go with or or even entertain
going with you you have meetings and you meet with
them and then you kind of just decide who's who's
the correct person based on based on instinct and
also too yeah chemistry and also the manager will
kind of push you in that right direction too we
had a manager at the time and they were like hey
our manager said I've got some other clients with
with him and so it's all very there's a lot of
synergy there when you got those calls and i'm
assuming it wasn't like you woke up and then
your phone's buzzing it's like one of those
no it's not like that hey jim this is so so but
how did were you like this is happening like I've
i've made it I mean it felt good to have an
agent but it felt good to have a manager too
but you quickly learned that like you've got to
do the work it's like okay well you sold something
that they weren't part of so they didn't get
commission so they're like what's next and so it's
like you've got to get back on the treadmill and
start like figuring things out and doing things
anytime we interview someone they naturally go
right away to their imdb for better or worse
and they they want to vet the person so you
have I believe six screenwriting credits okay
can you talk about how many you've written and how
screenwriting actually works and how selling them
actually works so you have six there but probably
you have many more that just aren't on your imdb
yeah that's a good question is I mean there's I've
probably written I don't know maybe 80 screenplays
probably optioned or been hired to write at
least 20 or 25 I don't even know anymore but
the thing is that there's different things too
it's like sometimes you can be hired to write it
write a script we wrote a script for Antoine Fuqua
who hired us to write this movie about the squad
so sometimes you're hired those don't get
made and then you don't they don't show up
on your imdb credits or you get hired
to write a pilot I've written several
pilots for tv shows that haven't been made
too and then sometimes things are optioned
or people buy things they don't get made so
it's always different but so that's probably the
I don't know there's been a lot the thing is
I have this rule of thumb to make a living
in the film business I have to have almost 20
projects in development or i'm working on at
any given time so whether i'm writing something
right now or have something out there or producing
something or trying to put something together or
something over here because the formula I think is
if I have 22 of them might get put together so
that's what i'm getting paid off of so because
this is how I pay the bills I have to think like
that and have to have a lot of things going on
but yeah that there's a lot of things a lot of
work you do that doesn't show up on imdb because
it's things that you wrote it didn't get made or
were optioned or you got hired to write and once
you get hired to write something if it doesn't
get made you don't own the script they own it
so I don't know what they're doing with several
projects we wrote a really big teenage zombie
thing for qed and they're not even around
anymore so I don't know who even owns the
rights that but we got paid so someone owns it
so there's there's things that happen like that
so imdb is not a full it doesn't i'm nothing
against imdb but it doesn't indic it's not a full
barometer or it's not your resume no no exactly
like I put my resume on linkedin like like I've
been hired to write or work on like I don't know
at least 20 things like we just had a tv project
that didn't work with a really big a-list director
but we got paid to write a pilot off of that they
had a tv show we sold the abc that almost got made
so there's a lot of things that you get paid you
work on but you build those relationships too
with those people so do you think most writers
want to take shortcuts no I don't think so I
think I don't think it's shortcuts but I think
they just don't dig in and do the work writing
a script a first draft and just going here you
go world it's like you may have to rewrite
it over and over especially when you haven't
done it often you have to learn how things
work and you have to get good at it's like
any other kind of like craft or anything else
it's like you don't become great in two months
you don't you can't ride a bike amazing in two
months or skateboard or do karate in two months
why do you think you can just write a screenplay
and the world's going to come looking for it
you have to get really good at it and you have to
learn every day and really watch a lot of people
you have to love films too you have to really be
into films and what's the structure of films and
what are they trying to say in scenes and just
really be passionate about it so that's that's my
thing is I don't think they take shortcuts but
they just don't do the work so maybe that's a
gigantic shortcut but you've got to get good at
your crap you got to keep doing keep rewriting
right if you want to be a professional right
you should have a ton of scripts especially
if you're young keep writing a bunch of things
you'll get everyone's going to get better most
professional writers are like on their seventh
or eighth script by the time they sell something
so they've gotten better each step of the way and
they've taken five or six years to get good at it
you were in a band correct yeah and what did
you play I played guitar oh okay okay great and
how long did it take you to
pick up different chords and
feel like you could be in front of an audience
oh the cool thing with the hair yeah that was so
long ago I mean yeah I don't I don't know I
started playing guitar I was 13 or 14 so it
was but I played in a band called hate department
back then which still are kind of around and were
pretty successful and great guy and they're still
friends of mine which is even more amazing all
those years later we're still all good friends
so yeah it was fun it was I thought I was gonna
be a rock star but instead I ended up being a
screenwriter but so it's not not the worst thing
in the world is there are there similarities
so you you needed maybe you didn't have to
go to school before you didn't go to GTI [Guitar
Institute] or you didn't go to whatever Juilliard
but you you learned different chords you probably
listened and mimicked different songs yeah a lot
of similarities it's funny you say that because
it's about I think about the rhythm of like things
like you understand rhythm in story and just same
thing with with music it's like you go here you
do that you go here you do that because we talk
about I talked with a lot of people about like
films kind of more popular type films not the
avant-garde kind films or like pop songs they're
not that complicated it's three-act structure
it's all there's you hit certain beats there's
this point where there's heartbreak all hope is
lost it's like a pop song it's very structured
it's not like a prog rock thing there's movies
like that but those are few and far between and
not the ones that everybody sees but for the most
part films are very structured and they they have
a rhythm and you know something bad is going to
happen here when you're watching you kind of know
you know the pacing of a movie they're they're
all you know at the end if something happens
weird at the end you're like that can't be the
end because you've seen it so many times in films
and just as music producers know this is going to
be a hit it fits these different things the same
with film yeah I mean not so much a hit but if
it's going to work or not get to some but there's
things like I said there's been a few screenplays
we've had out there where i'm like wow people
really like this they've really responded to it
more than I even thought so you never know how do
they leave comments or yeah they respond you mean
to the screenplays or yeah yeah right because you
just get yeah no because you just get up for
jobs they bring you in for other stuff or they
make an offer to buy it or so so that's yeah
if it gets you other work it's doing something
and get you a lot of meetings you read a
great screenplay you have an agent send it out
you can end up with like meetings all day long
with everybody is that its own sort of busy
work though where you you're taking so many
meetings but then you're not actually getting the
work done or it's not a bad thing it's building
relationships which paid off in the end what
makes 99 of screenplays unreadable I think it's
it might be the story it depe probably everyone
is there's a different problem with them
but they all have problems because I've seen a
lot of these but what you need to think about
too is the reader they don't think about who's
reading it and the person reading it they're
a professional has a stack of scripts sky-high
in their office so you need to understand like
if you don't grab the person the first two three
pages and you hear this all time but sometimes
you even need to like have something happen
that might not happen like that in the film
like is there a scene on page 23 that's super
exciting okay why not put that two or three pages
or section of it at the very beginning and then
create a flashback or do something so that the
it's exciting and really reads like a professional
script at the very beginning and that's the other
thing it has to read like a professional
script which means the dialogue has to be
well executed it has to move it has to have beats
you don't want to get bogged down in minutia you
don't want to do exposition you have to show don't
tell but the thing is it's not hard to get copies
of screenplays nowadays because the internet has
everything so there's a movie like your movie see
how they did it but you have to really grab people
right away it has to be professional all the way
through but if it's not professional first five
pages they're just gonna be like what is this and
you're asking someone to take an hour two hours
of their life to read your script so it better be
perfect and you better really do your work or
else you're wasting people's time is that when
a script consultant might be helpful because
let's suppose everyone is going to just tell
you it's great and they've never written a movie
before yeah a script consultant could be helpful
there's some things you just intuitively either
are gonna figure out or you're not but you can
you can get a script consultant to take you maybe
to the next level or show you things you're doing
wrong I said my view on that is is they're
good as long as you don't spend a lot of money
because I've had people come to me asking me
to fix a script or saying hey can you do this
I spent fifty thousand dollars on this script
I paid somebody to go to write it and they're
like somebody's never written a script so
you have to be very careful that you don't
lose your ass financially so but it could help
there's so many classes out there there's so many
things but I just always go back to watch movies
they're there they show you how to do it it's
already been done for you and just figure out how
your story fits into that formula and just kind
of like find those beats but that's why I think
why 99 of scripts are just they're not ready and
they're not at a professional level if you get
there it takes a lot of work to get it there
and do you think that people gave up too soon on
some of those unreadable scripts or that there's
just no way to sort of it's just lipstick on a
pig you can't really fix it yeah probably probably
both but I think a lot of it's just not doing the
work you just it's not some magic thing I think
people have this you know they envision smoking
cigarettes writing in the middle of the night like
it's glamorous it's not glamorous it's like if you
really want to get good at the people who make a
living in it are people who just stick to it grind
it out rewrite it rewrite it rewrite it the other
day I found there was a project I found like I was
cleaning out my computer I found like 40 drafts of
the script it's like that's a lot of drafts so and
that's what you have to do is really grind it and
work on it and make sure you get to professional
level and like I said you can find all these
scripts online if it's anything that's similar you
can find it if you you want to do a movie about
a guy in a food truck John Favreau did Chef watch
that you know by the way he's one of the best
that like beats in a film watch his films they all
have the same rhythm and the same beats it's there
yeah I love Chef that was great yeah so you
saved each draft of that screenplay you did
it four years yeah 40 drafts and you saved each
one this is just datum now because there's so
many on so many things so yeah what's the
purpose of saving each draft of a revision
just to kind of keep track I mean I probably not
really anything that has to do with screenwriting
just that's my process it's just easier to kind
of like I also back everything up on email and
things like that and another backup but you never
know when you need it or go back to something that
like you took out so I sometimes get a little
crazy to start cutting stuff out too I can like
just chop chop chop and then sometimes I chop
too much so I'll be like oh wait that was good
what was that one scene where the guy couldn't
aim the gun because he was shaking I cut that
out so I'll go back to older version and find
it just cut and paste it back in what really
irritates you about reading other screenplays
what irritates me is just when people haven't done
got it to where it should be at a level of reading
where they send you something and they go oh don't
read that wait I got this one or I changed that
or you or do you read it you talk to them they're
like oh I changed that it's like well that means
there was that famous josh olson article which
you can find online about reading people's scripts
which it's like if it's not ready to be read don't
send it to me because it's like like josh had
mentioned it's like asking somebody come over to
your house and paint for two hours you're taking
up two hours of somebody's time so don't give it
to them to read until it's like perfect and there
and if you want my notes and I give you some notes
don't be defensive about it either that's the most
irritating thing it's like don't say I want I want
your opinion and then you give somebody an opinion
and you say you need to fix this okay great thanks
and they're they have an attitude about it it's
like why'd you have me read it just tell you
it's great is it okay to question why you gave
a certain note is that yeah oh yeah definitely
definitely yeah oh yeah of course and what do
I know as much as I know I don't know anything
so it's like sometimes my notes might not even be
valid it's just this is what I think but sometimes
people don't even want to hear that they just
want they just want you to tell them it's great
did you ever catch that in yourself and really
work on that it sounds like you're okay with with
negative feedback it gets easier some I mean
it all kind of depends on who it comes from too
it's like I mean if somebody reads a script
of mine that's like never written a script and
they were like I don't like this and that I mean
probably my knee-jerk reaction like what do but
if it's a producer or somebody who I respect and
who's done a lot of work then I listen to him
but it does get easier to take the negative
feedback and like like I said before it's
about interpreting notes too sometimes people
can't explain why they don't like something
and you have to figure that out would you say
that 99 of what Hollywood makes is garbage no
there's some garbage but no I think I think most
films I mean most films get started with very good
intentions and look I've made a few movies that
i'm not happy with either but the process is not
a singular process you have to deal with producers
actors money guys distributors like even the Nick
Cage movie that I wrote it wasn't called Rage the
distributor called it Rage it's like really Rage
okay nobody's gonna make fun of Rage in
the cage but I had no control over that
so if you lose so much control in the
process that it takes a very very strong
director like somebody like quentin tarantino who
can say no to everybody and filter out the bad
that comes along that's you're making you're doing
art by committee so that's why sometimes things
they have great intentions maybe it was a
great script maybe the actor was amazing
but things got messed up along the way because
there's so many people's hands on the editor
the composer the director there's the screenwriter
the producer who shows up on set and wants to put
a motorcycle chase in the middle of the movie
that makes no sense and then you find out later
it's because he can get a free bmw motorcycle if
we put him in the movie things like that happen
so that's why sometimes movies don't work out but
I think most screenwriters and directors almost
all of them have the intention to make a great
movies just things get in the way or lack of money
or resources so if someone's at a certain level
then there's so much more creative control because
they can basically say no to people you need
that like one per that's why score says you
can make but you need a strong director writer
director who can like no one's going to question
that because then it at least keeps everything
focused there's very few of those people
but like I think paul thomas anderson I don't
think any producers are going to show up or money
guys and tell them what to do so it's or queen
tarantino or christopher nolan that's why they
can make really great films because the white
noise that's going on around them they can just
stop or just ignore it or or people just scared
even mess with them because people want to get
their ideas in a film too you'll have money guys
who you've never even met who gave some money
on a film show up and like give an idea and then
other ones are great and actually have good ideas
so there's just so many people that are involved
in a film that it's hard sometimes to keep it
focused so I think that's the problem with things
that sometimes because a lot of movies on Netflix
look like they had good intentions and like I said
I've i've worked on a few that like start off over
here and ended up over there it happens why don't
you outline screenplays well I think I described
before what I like to do I like to just do all
the beats everything I like to write the first act
have the the second act turn and the the ending
because I found that like if you are too kind of
sometimes too methodical about figuring it all
out up front you can't discover certain things
you'll find things that are happening along
the way that are like surprises even to you and
sometimes that stuff becomes even better you're
like oh I didn't think about that but how do I get
these guys from the end of act one to the second
second act turn and you just discover it I know
some people that like to do a complete beat sheet
you have to do that when you're hired to write
things you have to give them a you can't do that
that's but for a spec purpose or writing a script
you can have your own process so it feels a
little stale sometimes when you have everything
beated out and you're like okay because that
two weeks you're writing out the beat sheet
you might get a better sense of your story and
your characters four weeks into writing the script
and find things along the way that like oh I never
thought about that guy like that or this like this
do you get bored when things are too easy
yeah yeah like a challenge yeah because I get the
sense you figure things out very easily and so
you want to go to the next level yeah especially
well I think too you have to kind of as a
screenwriter like reinvent like where you want
to go every couple years too unless you're you're
happy in the area the area that you're in so yeah
no I guess I do yeah I never thought of it like
that but yeah I think i'm always trying to like
reinvent or kind of come to get the next level or
do certain things and figure out how it works so
yeah I do I like to make things harder myself no
but that you just enjoy a challenge you like to be
you you don't it's kind of like I hate to use like
a lab rat I mean i'm sorry but they they get the
cheese they get out okay they they solve the thing
yeah if you want to really boil it down to that
but we all kind of want something more because if
things are too easy then it's just everything's
boring and then you can become depressed
yeah and I don't know where I get it from but i'm
really in to like getting things finished like
like I think I said earlier i'm never happy
till something's done I enjoy the process more
but I've been on movie shoots and things where
it's getting made i'm miserable the whole time
because i'm I still think something's gonna go
wrong when it's finished and then I also have a
weird amnesia when projects are finished I don't
think about them again I just move on I think of
most of the films I've worked on that have been
made I've maybe watched once I don't ever go back
watch them or think about them and John Carpenter
has that attribute if you watch the brian de palma
documentary he has that not that i'm comparing
myself to them but it's like a good thing to have
if you're gonna do this professionally it's like
once you're done with something you just move on
you don't even think about that old project again
it's like what's next how is someone who doesn't
outline so great at structure that's a good
question I think I just know how films work
and watch a lot of films and just just know
that the structure will find itself because
like i'm very open to like okay and I think I
always have a good understanding like tracking
tracking characters is a very important
thing in script you have to make sure that
somebody hasn't disappeared too far out of the
story like if you have a bad guy in something
and he shows up page 20 and then shows up page 40.
he can't disappear until page 90. we have to see
what he's doing at some point so I think I always
have a really good understanding of like making
sure we track people and like okay we've seen
this character do this now we have to go back
to that person we have to go find that person
catch them all up put put them where they go so
and how do you remember do you almost have like
bullet points like okay there's there's joe over
here there's there's mary and then making sure
that i'm i'm still seeing their names somewhere
within the last few pages yeah it's it's I don't
know it's kind of easy for me it seems easy I know
some people will like chart out where characters
are and so everybody has their own process
and you can do note cards and things like that
I kind of always have an idea where they're
coming going and and also too that's also part
of you get better right into you you throw away
any characters that don't mean anything to the
story if you're a newer writer and you have all
these characters that don't mean anything you're
going to have a hard time tracking people but if
you really pay attention to films especially
commercial ones they don't have a lot of
characters there might be a lot of people in it
but it centers around a small group of people
the godfather might be one thing but I mean if
you look at indiana jones it's always just him
and then they'll go to the bad guys and then they
kind of like you're along the journey with him
so it's yeah it's more like about tracking those
people but most studio films don't have a lot of
people marvel films aside when the avengers have
like 8 000 characters but even then if you watch
the avenger movies they're great at tracking
all those different people they keep coming
going out of the story just enough so you don't
forget them what about something like crash crash
that's a little bit different but that's yeah
that's that's more the extreme but I mean but I
mean that's a kind of different film the still is
anchored though by it's anchored more by stories
so yeah that's a good example but that's a little
bit different that's and I don't know how many
kind of movies like that they're doing nowadays
because that was kind of hit for a while the
non-linear bouncing around all these multiple
stories so yeah that's a different kind of movie
right but it works yeah it was excellent can you
provide a few questions that a screenwriter or
producer should ask themselves before writing
a movie or or getting involved with a movie
yeah I think the biggest question is how do I
get made if it's if it's some kind of gigantic
sci-fi epic that cost 400 million dollars it's
it's like a non-starter but I think you just
need to really ask you have to be passionate
about it too and really want to see it to the
finish line because it takes a lot of work I mean
you want to get paid but money's your main drive
that's not always what happens there's things
I've worked on and worked on them so long that
even though I got paid well I probably end up
making a dollar an hour dollar fifty if you
timed it out but it was like I was like i'm
determined to get this film finished so I think
that's the biggest question because why write
something if you're not going to try to really
get it made or use it to get other jobs or create
a career if it's just for your friends to read
that's a whole other thing all together how
many films do you think have been made where
they were too ambitious in terms of the budget
and oh lots people just couldn't be told no
that happens all the time and I mean
it just happens in the sense that like
you start and you something goes wrong
because with indie films the budgets are so
precise that if something goes wrong it could
screw the whole movie up you don't get to shoot
that you now it's not 25 days it's 20 days
there's so many things that can go wrong but
I think that's where that has very little do with
the screenplay but more to do with the director
being able to like change things and adjust things
on the fly and go okay that we can cut that out we
can move that to there and we can save this
whole thing and not make have it be a mess
but it happens a lot so if you are hired for a
screenplay and you do have to do a beat sheet
and you submit it and then a couple
weeks later you come up with better ideas
are you stuck with that that same beat sheet and
that same progression no you can I mean what you
can do is is if you're hired to write something
you have to communicate with the producers because
every step is tiered it's like you get paid to
start you get paid when you turn in the beat sheet
or the treatment you get paid to start writing the
script but if you start coming up with changes or
figure things out you can just get the producers
on the phone who who have paid you to write it
and throw your ideas at them and they may love
them they might they might just say stick with
the beach they might say oh that's great let's
try that so it's a process you you have to be
in really good communication when you're taking
money from people and working with somebody and
keep them informed but you can't make wholesale
changes and go here it is because your agent will
be calling you go why are they calling me all
pissed off and you did this wrong so you have to
kind of like you have to do what they want they're
hiring you to do something it's like if they hired
you to paint the house gray you can't paint it
red and say oh I thought this section would look
better like this so you're their employee but
you get the job by coming in with your own take
and your own pitch which they like but then
it becomes theirs when they start paying you
and then you just have to work with them but
yeah most great producers if you come up with
a great idea you just run it by them they're like
oh that's much better so they're not resistant to
it but you have to you can't just decide to
go in the third act a totally different way
would you say a lot of screenwriters fail because
they're not writing movies that Hollywood wants to
make yeah I mean you have to like it goes
back to what it's talking about with like
the business side of it you have to make money
for people it's not it's not a situation where
people just trying to throw money away or light
it on fire so if you cannot create a screenplay
that like producers think they can at least
get their money back and some because sales
agents take a cut everybody takes a cut so you
have to actually make some profit on top of it
someone along the line is going to lose money
and that's not what most people want to do
there's like I said there's some billionaires that
just want to throw money at things and don't care
but those are few and far between so I think
yeah you have to be very honest with yourself
about what people are buying you can't make some
weird film that like speaks to you and your small
group of friends and expect somebody to give you a
million dollars to make it and no one else gets it
and the universal appeal that you had talked about
previously just sci-fi horror in action well that
has foreign appeals so yeah that that's part of
the process too like you have to keep in mind
that like the form the the foreign mark there's
two markets the domestic market which is north
America and then the foreign market which is the
rest of the world that what a some movie about
skateboarders in Hollywood in love might not
translate in Japan the same way a horror movie
would or a thriller so you it that that's a whole
other section of money that comes in on a film
so yeah it becomes harder and harder the more
esoteric something is now that's where sometimes
the greatest movies come from like gasparno
makes insane crazy esoteric movies that that
do really well and are cool but again those
are few and far between and in America I think
they're less likely to take chances and Europe
I've worked with a few European producers
and they seem a little bit more into the art
they also treat directors and writers a little
differently with a little bit more respect
and are more the auteur theory than here but
it's it's part of the problem is if you don't
do stuff that people can make money off of it
doesn't have to be commercial but it has to
have a market the opening pages of a screenplay
important or cliche well cliches work for a
reason but if you do it well then it works
so you mean what do you mean what's the context
of the opening how important are they are people
really tossing something in a pile in a slush pile
based on yeah they do but it's like if you can
grab like you have it has to play professional it
has to read professional and it also has to have
something happening in the beginning and it can't
be just exposition people sitting around talking
yeah it is and I've even seen here's another thing
people don't know is that producers will look at
what the genre is and see the page count at the
end and it's like if you've written a script
that's like 150 pages they're like this person
doesn't know what they're doing because no one
should write a script over 115 pages unless you're
Quenton Tarantino or like Paul Thomas Anderson and
if it's like a horror movie it's 140 pages they're
going to be like what that is going on because
how many pages they're all I mean if you look
at most professional scripts they're always
studio scripts or anything they're 105 to like 112
pages like clockwork horror movies a little bit
less they're like 98 to like 104 but so they see
so many scripts and they know they can and you've
got to keep in mind your time you're competing
for their time against professional scripts
they're getting so it's got to be really awesome
and it's got to be bombastic in the beginning
not not you're blowing stuff up but you have to
grab them somehow do something somehow that really
shows like oh wow I haven't seen that before wow
that's interesting have somebody have adrenaline
needles jammed in their heart on the first like
first line wakes up where am I you do something
and that doesn't necessarily have to be how
the story starts but you have to figure out a
way to like make it work and have the beginning
be something that's really really interesting
how much time do you spend on the first page of
a screenplay not much maybe like 10 minutes maybe
five it just depends on the on the flow but a lot
of times when I first start something I'll just be
like this and I kind of know because I've thought
about the beats of what I want to happen and then
I'll go back and rework it so it's like i'm more
concerned not necessarily with all the dialogue
line for line but more what the scene is saying
like what's the beginning middle and end of the
scene and what's trying to get across and then go
back and finesse all that stuff and two now I've
I do a new system now where I don't write any
description while i'm writing I'll just say
describe office and then go back and do that
at the end because it doesn't have anything to
do really with the story it slows you down yeah
yeah would paneling file yeah exactly and go back
and do all that one time at the end interesting
so you put in like a little space holder yeah
explain city explain the car describe here now
if it's really important the story maybe I'll put
it in but if it's just like if the spy movie it's
like and you got to describe Paris as the sunrise
comes up I'll do that later just put established
Paris they just keep going because that's not
that's easy to do how do you write a screenplay
in two weeks I think a bigger question how do
you write screenplay in two days because
I've done that it's actually like the time
writing is differs but it's like how much have you
thought about it because there's times I think I
said earlier I'll think about something for two
three weeks before I even touch the keyboard about
the story and run a lot of in my head and if I get
a big chunk of it it's like I could just write 20
30 pages in a day but I've thought about it it's
not just i'm like looking at the blank page i'm
not one of those people stares at the computer
I'll go for walks I'll get coffee do whatever
ride a bike that's where I get all my ideas
and for some reason driving but it's like you
almost get in this zone of like thinking about
things and sometimes when i'm stuck I'll go for
a walk I can come back and write like five or
six scenes because I just saw it on my head so
yeah that's that's the process I mean there's
one screenplay I wrote two two days because I
forgot when I was supposed to deliver it and this
is when I was first writing and then it became
it was supposed to be a half million dollar little
action movie that became a 10 million dollar film
and I wrote in two days so but there were a
lot of parameters set on that job it had to
be one location don't want to change wardrobe
the actor can't talk too much because he's an
MMA fighter like there are all these things and I
just was like what I kept putting it off because I
really didn't want to do it I got paid and I was I
wrote in a weekend and then it became a 10 million
dollar film they didn't really use the script it
kept changing and changing but it so it you never
know strange things happen in this business what's
an example of lingering too long on a film project
that's a good question it's you mean if you
write a script and you keep trying to get it
made and getting it made and it's not working yeah
I don't know it depends on who you're talking to
if you don't have any contacts and you're slowly
building up who and getting people to read it
it could take a process of years but if you had a
project that you gave to your agent your manager
and you had some producers read and everybody was
kind of like not really jiving with it I would say
put it away and write something else so it
kind of depends on where you're at it's like
if you've got a great script but you don't have
access to get the proper people to read it for
a couple years it's going to take a couple years
so your instinct should tell you everything though
people are really responding the right people if
you can get some right people to really read it if
you do one of those coverage things or something
and they give you 50 pages of coverage maybe
you're in trouble but so so that's I don't really
know the answer to that but I think you just have
to use your instinct on what's working what's not
sometimes you write a script and it's not good
enough how do again just instinct it's like I've
worked on things where it's like it feels great
but it doesn't feel amazing like
it's it feels like it's almost there
or maybe the first 60 pages are seem really
amazing but the the third act doesn't work
so you just have to know I wrote
a high script recently I was
working on I got inspired and quickly wrote this
high school I think the first 60 pages are great
but the the third act is horrible which usually
not something that happens it's not horrible
but it doesn't keep up with the rest of the
film and i'm not getting any inspiration to
to come up with the third act so I just put
it away for now maybe I'll revisit it in six
months or three months or two years from now but
you just kind of have to know when things are
working and when they're not are you banging
your head against the wall that's not good
if there's something that you feel is like you
can't crack the nut all the way through or figure
it out you should maybe think about something
or put it down for a while sometimes you can
put something down and come back to it there's
a lot of people I know a lot of directors I know
who worked on things for years they put things
away and they come back to them and they'll be
like hey wow this is pretty cool but they have a
fresh perspective on it all was there a project
that taught you how important your instinct was
maybe you didn't pay attention to it before when
it came to writing yeah I think it happened
I think the the movie Rage that we did the
screenplay was called tokarev originally I love
this movie this british film called the long good
friday which has bob hoskins in it it's from the
early 80s and I was like I want to do something
like that and I kept thinking and then I mentioned
to a few people and they didn't know the movie or
they just were like yeah whatever and I was like
no this could make a really cool thing tony it was
that kind of movie the story is completely
different but it kind of had the same tone
and that was when we were writing a lot of horror
things just doing horror shaun and I were just
doing horror that's all I was working on and I
was like no this thriller is a cool thriller and
it's got a lot of things that are going for
it and I wrote like half the script in like
one day I just kept thinking about then I sent
over Sean he did some work on and we finished it
and it got amazing response and it was one
of those times where I was like I think
I need to move from horror into thriller stuff and
this is like a really cool idea and it worked and
everybody loved the script and it got made and did
really well for us so because of that you realized
okay I can trust myself yeah yeah same thing
happened with writing a pilot too for that we
sold the abc it's like we never worked in tv and
then one day I was like we should write a pilot
we decided to write a pilot and had to find
copies of pilots to even know the structure
and I think we called our manager it's like
hey can you send us some pilots and wrote a
pilot without ever knowing anything about pilots
and there was a bidding war between abc and nbc
for when we sold it didn't get made but it was
like another one of those times where it's like
I don't know never worked on tv but it feels like
maybe we should do some tv so yeah just follow a
lot of instinct stuff works don't know why do
you worry about your movie ideas being stolen
no because if you only have one idea and it's
stolen and you can't come up with anything else
then you're in the wrong business it happens I
mean it's it happens you it's just part of the
business also too I honestly believe there's like
once you think something and a producer said this
to me once it kind of goes into the ether
and other people can pull it out of the air
and look there's a lot of people who
independently have the same ideas
I've seen it happen time and time
again and you can't worry about it it's
I mean it and there's no way to prove it it's a
different situation if you sent someone a script
and you have proof that they read it and then they
come up with something completely different but
if there's some kid in new york writes something
and somebody somewhere else who doesn't know each
other have almost very similar ideas that's just
happenstance so you can't really worry about that
kind of stuff and if you only have one idea and
you're worried about somebody stealing it then
good luck because you have to have a million
ideas to do this for a living did you worry about
it more before you talked to this manager who said
that they're in the ether they're in the zeitgeist
and no they can be pulled out and no not really
it's just because it could happen it's it's like
but just sometimes people come up with almost
identical ideas just happens but you can't worry
about that stuff you have to just keep going
yeah yeah what about having a script stolen
I mean there's ways to here's the thing I
have to like give people lectures about all
the time is copyright your scripts don't
register them with the wga I mean you can
but there's different levels of protection if
you copyright a script and then you have legal
recourse you have to like sue somebody or
something you can actually sue for legal
fees if it's just registered or something else
you can't there so you have to always copyright
your script so if you're worried about that
spend 55 whatever it is copyright it that's the
best protection in the world what would you do if
somebody blatantly stole one of your screenplays
well if someone blatantly stole it I would have
some kind of paper trail that would be the reason
i'd use it they blatantly stole it like I sent it
to them or something like that but you also have
a system of like you have a lawyer you have an
agent you have a manager who sends it out at a
professional level and no one steals anybody's
ideas it's kind of protected by them doing that
work but if you were a screenwriter in the midwest
and you sent it out you just have to keep track of
who's here's the problem you can't copyright an
idea either so you can't you can copyright the
entire script but if somebody takes a similar
idea and writes a different version of it
there's not much you can do that's why there's
a lot of movies that are very similar movies
so I wouldn't worry too much about it and
just just get really good at screenwriting and
you'll be fine can you take us through the process
of how you pitched abc yes this is a question I
get asked a lot is with tv projects are very
different than film tv you don't have to have
a pilot you let me rephrase that you have to have
a pilot if you have to write out a pilot if you
don't have a history of writing like if you don't
have a track record and haven't sold anything
now if you have you don't have to write a pilot
you have to write a pitch but for most people who
are coming up you have to actually write the pilot
for the show now what you do is you write a pilot
for a tv show it's whether it's 30 pages 60 pages
you write that pilot episode and then you write a
tv pitch now the pitch is only is would be a
verbal pitch you would pitch which is only 10
minutes long and all you cover is what the show's
about the characters the beats and the pilot
and where it's going the next few seasons you
don't need to write like a 50 page bible that's
not what they want to hear tv pitches you're only
supposed to pitch from 8 to 10 minutes in a room
and that's it now they they will ask you a bunch
of questions afterwards if they're interested
but you don't need to like do work I see these
people who write these 50 page bibles and do all
this work and you don't have to do it that's not
how you get a tv show sold tv show all you need
is a like I said the proper pitch and which is
a format which is just simply about the show the
characters a few beats in the pilot where season
one's going and a few beats for season two that's
all they care about they care about the characters
more than anything and what the show's about
because you got to live with those characters for
years and you have to have a pilot now more likely
if you sell it they're going to make you rewrite
the whole pilot anyway but you have to show to the
execs that are buying things that you can perform
and write it that's why if you don't have a track
record you have to have a pitch and a pilot but if
you do have a track record you don't necessarily
have to write a pilot and they don't even want you
to nowadays because they want to be involved in
every step of writing the pilot so not only having
great characters but characters that can actually
grow and go somewhere how are you factoring
any of that into this eight-minute pitch or no
that's for them to decide can we go anywhere with
this character no that that goes in your pitch
and when you cover season one and you talk about
where the the show's going like let's say it's ten
episodes you don't go episode by episode you just
say kind of start of season one middle season one
end of season one but a lot of what you're
talking about is where the relationships go like
if character a becomes involved with character
b and then character c is upset about that so
it's not so much plotty as opposed to where the
characters fall into the storyline and how they
change and adjust because he said tv you're living
it's like being married with these characters
if you have a show and you're going to do 50
episodes people have to have a reason to keep
coming back to these characters so they have to
grow and change and things have to happen to them
is there a certain time of year when you can
pitch networks yes not let me rephrase that not
so much anymore it used to be you would pitch
like in I think it was july through september
because then they would be starting to set up for
the next season but now with streamers and all
that it's kind of year-round they'll take pictures
any time it's only really in regards to abc's cbs
nbc like the big networks they still stay more
on a schedule because they still like to have a
lot of shows come out in september october that
kind of time frame that they've been doing for
decades but nowadays no not so much now they'll
listen to pitches almost any time of the year
so it's kind of the streamers have changed
all that there's no real season to anything
what are the steps to pitching a tv
hoof show lot well first of all you've got to
get a great pitch together and usually you have a
producer you're working with who's taking you into
the the networks or a company like the one we when
we sold our show to abc we had first sold set it
up at Lionsgate so we went in to abc nbc we went
to every network in one week they make you do it
almost like consecutively so that if one person is
interested someone else will also come aboard and
they'll get them playing against each other so you
almost go like you'll get a pitch grid that's like
24 pitches in like four days and you just go place
to place to place do the same thing but you bring
your producers in and the real work is working
with your producers on the pitch because when we
were very lucky that the Lionsgate execs had sold
a lot of shows and they were really awesome people
and they made us do it with them work it over
and work it out and had us they literally time us
they'd be like okay you only got eight minutes go
and you do the pitch they give you notes you
rework it you rewrite it and you do it again and
again and they're the final like kind of decision
makers about what the pitch is going to be like
because they're the sellers really even though you
wrote the show so that there's going to be back
to back this is pitch week and so I you plan out
your whole sort of life schedule around that and
wardrobe and coming in with this producer like how
stressful is that to know that you're going to be
on even though writers sort of don't want that
yeah i'm very stressful you just have to do it
you just do it I mean a pitch gets
easier and easier the more you do it
so the first one or two might
be a little clunky but you just
the whole process is to really give them what the
show's about tv moves super fast faster than phil
you get what the show's about and then you try
to get it after eight minutes into conversation
get a conversational where hopefully they ask you
a bunch of questions and you talk more about the
show but you only talk at them for like a good
eight minutes can you talk about the bible versus
the pitch versus writing a pilot yes well the the
pilot's a pilot whether it's a 30 page pilot 60
page pilot which you have the pitch is like maybe
a six or seven page document maybe less that you
you verbally will read to them in the room you
usually don't leave it behind you go in because
they like I mean with covid it's a little bit
different but they've been doing it on zoom
you leave the pitch you do the pitch but you
don't leave it behind now a bible doesn't get
created until the show has been ordered so a lot
of people get mixed up on these the bible is like
the bible that explains the characters the show
so it's it adds con creates continuity through the
writer's room and from episode to episode so a lot
of people will be interested in creating a bible
it's like it's an unnecessary step you don't do
that until later in the process there's only two
things you need a pilot and a pitch if you're a
new kind of screenwriter wanting to sell a tv show
so don't worry about how do you make the pitch
bible or excuse me don't worry about how you make
the bible because we get we see that once that
once it's greenlit or once it's getting close to
to being told yes then yeah you're putting the
cart before the horse okay it doesn't need to
be done and most times too like if they like
your pilot more than likely it doesn't I mean
sometimes they'll be like this is great let's
shoot this but more than likely they're going
to want you to rewrite the entire pilot with their
input like there's something they really dig they
like it but they're going to want to do it more
their way and if it's a big network or tnt or
amc they know what they want so they're gonna
be like this is great but let's do it this way
how much time did you spend writing on the pitch
it took several passes at it so maybe it was like
about a month where you maybe I mean not a month
full time but you kind of work on it send it over
work on it send it over practice it a couple
times do it and just get everybody's input so
we were very lucky like I said we had lines get
involved which there were several execs so they
would all hear it and then they put in their two
cents or say justice change that that's great
so yeah it's like a sales process it's
it's a creative process but it's also like
selling something so that's a little bit different
of a mindset so you have those eight minutes but
then what about the talking points that are more
conversational afterwards are you preparing if
they ask me this then i'm gonna say that yes
we would always write down some talking points
just to have them as additional things but
usually they would ask enough questions that
it would get conversational and you would you
would encourage it and try to talk about it
and also we brought in a few visual presentation
things too like boards that had kind of the world
and some character stuff so we know we realize
really quickly that if you bring those in
it's kind of uncomfortable for if you're pitching
to five or six execs for them to just stare at
you the whole time for them so if you have like
tone boards and things they can look away and
I think it makes it more relaxing for them
too because it's a very unnatural thing for
you just to be talking at somebody and
then just looking at you the whole time
so and the tone boards made it more conversational
but yeah we actually after one or two of those
started writing out talking points that kept
coming up and things to add on top of the pitch
that were like more conversational so by the by
the 23rd pitch you had it down so well that you
were like why didn't I do it this way to start out
but yeah a little bit you get really good at by
the time you're done so yeah what other materials
are needed to pitch a network show it depends it's
I've heard some tv execs say like thank god you
didn't bring in a visual presentation with the the
the the monitors and all the stuff
and because they see so many of those
so I don't think it's really necessary because
these are smart executives if you're pitching
to a tv exec at Netflix or somewhere they know
how tv works and they know if it's a show so I
it helps depends if you're world building
then maybe it might help a little bit more but
if it's like a drama in the midwest they get
it they you don't have to show them this looks
what uncle charlie looks like and this is they
know so so you don't really need to bring much
but you have to have just a really solid quick
pitch and and back it up and be able to answer
any questions they have too and the weird
thing is sometimes they don't ask anything
and they're the ones who buy it so you never know
sometimes they'll ask a million questions you're
like oh that went great and then they pass so
that's pretty much what you got to do is just
just follow your your what you think is best
for that certain type of show obviously if it
was something based on ip you would bring in
vip if it was a comic book you'd bring in big
blow-ups so the comic book can go these
are our characters but if it's a small
intimate thing you would I don't think you need to
do that how many times have you pitched a tv show
pitched several that one sold a couple sometimes
they don't sell and for various reasons like
maybe somebody else just announced a show
that was very similar so that happens as well
and pitched a couple where we got hired to write
pilots but they never got on air so probably like
five or six times and two or three of them sold
but it's becoming more and more really competitive
as of late because now everyone's in tv a couple
years ago it was a little bit easier now they
want you to bring a whole package to pitch a tv
show right now you kind of need to bring in a
director of the pilot the show runner the the
the producers who are they want big producers
to kind of get it going so it's become much
more competitive than was a couple years ago
can you talk about how you actually got in the
room did someone that brought you in well I was
fortunate enough that that I was with paradigm
agency at the time and had an amazing tv agent
rich rogers and he did it all he just said look
I love this pilot you guys are going to sell it
and let's go to production companies first so
we did that we went to six or seven production
companies Lionsgate paid paid us and bought the
project and then became our producers and then
we went out and then Lionsgate sets you up with
the the networks and so it's a two-step process
first your agent will get you with producers
if the producers latch on then the producers
take it over from there and then they will
set everything up for you and take it out
and they make all the meetings and they have a
track record usually with these networks and have
other shows on there with them so so it's two
step process so they want rept writers you're
not just meeting somebody at a coffee shop and
hey what I want to bring you in why don't you
yeah I mean I think tv is a little bit yeah
harder than features to get in with with
features you can get in I think a little bit
easier meet producers and talk tv is a little bit
tougher without an agency but it depends on what
you're trying to do if you're a screenwriter and
you want to work in tv are you trying to sell a
show or are you trying to become a staff writer
staff writer is a lot easier selling a show is a
big you've got to put all these pieces together
and have all this stuff thought out now if you
write a good spec pilot and you want to get on a
tv show you can maybe find an agent to send it out
to people and or meet people or work in a writer's
room like I said before and being a writer's
assistant and get on a staff that's a little bit
that's a lot easier than selling a show selling
your shows you're the creator and that's your show
so people now are bringing in
teams you said so show runners
they want to package everything and even sometimes
actors so and they would all come in not barring
coven not being around but they would all
come in previously as a group yeah yeah
which that's a hard package to turn down when
jj abrams walks in with his whole crew and so
but that's the that's the advantage to hooking up
your pilot or your project with a big production
company they can do that they can go get
show runners they can go get those people
so tv's become very very competitive as of late
and it wasn't always seems like but it's it's
become tv's become a beast last few years
so it's it's really great people making tv
so that's another question you have to ask
yourself is like look who i'm competing against
so it might be better for somebody starting
out to really write a spec pilot and try to
get in a writer's room and try that should be
your goal is like how do I get on a staff and
write for two three years make a living at it
and then make those connections get the agent
then you can write your own project and get it
out there the bigger a production budget the more
problems no I've seen that I have found that you
have the same problems on a million dollar movie
that you do on a 10 million dollar movie and I
know people who have produced 100 million dollar
movies that said they're the same problems on a
million dollar movie on 100 million movie it's
always time money actors producers screenplay
it's the exact same problem just more's at stake
is the stress level higher because more
is at stake I would think so I've never
produced 100 million movie but I get stressed
out producing just a million dollar movie so
I would think so but across the board you've heard
from others that it's the same does it matter
same problems that just the pay is a lot
less if you're doing a million dollar film
versus 100 million dollar film so yeah I've
heard people say the exact same problems
did you pitch in the mirror did you no okay no.